hi I'm Erik Bosse and now that Rick and
Morty season 3 is sadly over it's time
to do what any true Rick and Morty fan
does during a hiatus re-watch every
episode and find even more funny stuff
that's right despite watching every
episode of season 3 several times before
I make these videos I did miss a few
amazing subtle jokes and references and
I have to hand it to you guys you've
been very good at pointing out when I
miss stuff or mispronounce things wear
shirts you don't like or put ads and
videos or exist at all I secretly hate
all that stuff too especially the
existing let's run crew season 3 yet
another time to see what else we missed
maybe you caught these maybe you didn't
I'm just covering my bases here don't be
a dick starting with season 3 episode 1
the rick shakely exemption there were a
few things in this episode first when
summer and morty go through the garage
and search for rick's portal gun there's
a quick shot showing a portrait of
doofus rick this remember has a callback
to season 1 the clothes work counters of
the rick kind episode in which jerry hit
it off with doofus rick I assume this
portrait belongs to him also I can't
believe I missed this but in Rick's rant
at the end of the episode which was an
obvious call back to the rant at the end
of the pilot episode there was this line
in that pilot episode Rick famously said
a hundred years Rick and Morty and this
season aired roughly three years after
season 1 so now Rick says 97 years yeah
man thanks mr. goldenfold okay moving on
to episode 2 Rick Nancy in the stone a
big reference I forgot to mention was
the hand gestures Morty's giant arm
makes in the blood oh yeah sorry pro
wrestling fans those are obviously the
Hulk Hogan ear cup and the John Cena
can't see anyways so great
next up episode 3 pickle ring I loved
all the die-hard parody references and
pickle Rick's assaults on the terrorist
based so much that I overlooked nods do
another action movie I love John wick
specifically there was the Russian
nickname the guards gave to the pickle
man some of my men are calling you
Selenia the pickle man
wives - this is a reference to the
Russian gangsters in John wick who
called him the Baba Yaga the cool him
Baba Yaga boogeyman
then there was episode 4 The Vindicator
episode now early in this episode Rick
says this line Ringo is more powerful
than these guys every week some of you
pointed out how God is kind of a spin on
googas the alien creature we actually
saw later in episode 10 and yeah both
our reference to Justin roiland channel
101 short Google we're gonna call them
and yeah this episode was full of
superhero parody references including
the previously killed off members of The
Vindicator lady Calypso Diablo Verde and
lady katana and I didn't put this out of
this time but yeah these could be
references to the characters from
Suicide Squad with Lady Calypso being
enchantress Diablo Verde being Diablo
and lady katana being Harley Quinn just
kidding katana
obviously moving on to episode 5 the
were leaderly conspiracy with Rick and
Jerry it was a fun one because the
trippy temporal field sequence was kind
of oppressed for viewers a lot of you
saw the triangle symbolism and the
all-seeing eye as a reference to bill
cipher from gravity falls gravity falls
is kind of a sister animated series to
Rick and Morty and there actually were a
lot of gravity falls references and
other episodes of season in while others
saw the pagan imagery with the goat head
as a reference to the movie altered
states which looking at it now yeah it
does definitely seem like an influence
on all this imagery meanwhile in this
episode the appearance and the inhuman
groaning of giant inside out summer and
Beth seems like it was very much
inspired by the look of the Titans in
attack on Titan now the next episode
episode 6 was rest and relaxation with
toxic Rick and Morty and one detail I
liked was that at the end of the episode
when Rick calls Morty to try to trick
him into reemerging with his toxic self
notice how Morty doesn't hang up the
phone call even though he knows Rick is
tracing it no even though healthy Morty
is a total douche acceptance is toxic
side to be his through complete self now
my favorite episode of the season was
episode 7 the Atlantis mixed up the
Citadel episode it was full of great
details including the one I pointed out
at the end with evil Morty's new logo
it's the old city
with a Morty em now stabbing down
through the Rick but what I missed was
that this violent takeover was
foreshadowed earlier in the episode a
few thug Morty's vandalized a citadel
logo by tagging an M over it just like
the design of the logo later and in
honor of Blade Runner 2049 coming out
this weekend one of the many Rick's in
the Citadel that I overlooked was this
obvious Deckard Rick in a trench coat
episode 8 was more teas mind blowers and
with all these quick anthology shorts a
few details simply slipped through the
cracks
first notice how when Bebo dies that
they can warn themselves it's good the
animators included this fun visual
detail of the life in Bebo's eyes fading
out also along with the basics female
bezoar pians intro floor hands in the
collectors menagerie there were also a
few red Angry Birds in the upper left
corner and then there was this great
memory of Rick and Morty interrogating
this alien rewatching this season this
joke was actually set up back in the
pickle Rick episode let the pickle over
what I'm gonna touch it you're gonna
tell me it's an alien dick or something
and now this memory shows why Morty
instinctively doesn't trust Rick when he
tells me to touch stuff okay next up
episode 9 the ABCs of beth early in the
episode I pointed out how Rick's Yuto
box contains a meeseeks box and a vinda
beacon but if you look in there even
more closely you can also barely make
out the memory eraser tool from the
previous episode along with a box of
simple Rick's cookies from the Citadel
episode and then this next one is an
embarrassing oversight by me I was so
caught up in making Alien and Predator
connections with Chiara and the varix
that she hunts that I described the
severed head of the varix as a crawling
face hugger xenomorph from alien and
obviously this is more clearly a
reference to John Carpenter's The Thing
when the spider crab legs pop out of
norris's severed head it's honestly my
favorite visual effect and one of my
favorite movies and I'll never forgive
myself for missing this and another
detail we missed this episode when Matt
lovingly looks at the family on the
fridge one of the magnets has this logo
of the Galactic Federation how I assume
that's leftover from the beginning of
the season when earth was still under
Federation control and that brings us to
the final episode the breakdown for
which just came out but I didn't have
time to fit these in notice how Rick
smugly sips a martini as he shows up to
save the day for the president that's a
callback to the Vindicator episode this
is a move he picked up from Vance
Maximus renegade star soldier when
he swooped in like an ass yeah rick has
become everything he hates and then
another call back from The Vindicator
episode Rick solves the
israeli-palestinian conflict which
remember was the same hot-button issue
Rick considered too awkward to talk
about fellas Israel it's just something
Rick starts talking about when he's
blackout drunk so whoo yeah it sounds
like Rick actually was enough of an
expert on geopolitics to solve this
crisis which of these miss jokes do you
think I should be most mad at myself for
should we all go easy on me since I
wrote hosted and produced these
breakdown videos at breakneck speed on
very little sleep one of the fear that
Commodores were gonna yell at me about
intrusive ads that I personally had no
choice in doing I'm just kidding you
guys are the best if you haven't already
go check out my breakdowns of each
episode for all the jokes that cut the
first time around but hopefully there
are still even more out there to be
found on sixth and seventh and a
millionth viewings like and share this
video and if you haven't already
subscribed into rockstars and if you
really like us you can contribute to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kenny Smith you can't
be up on Twitter at EA vas with any
thoughts or theories you have or follow
the new rock stars at new rock stars for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye